bastions what that guess what what just
what pet why I have a billion-dollar
idea man here's your idea suck it come
here billion-dollar idea you know how
many times I have to hear messages like
this Pat I got a billion-dollar idea how
we gonna be the next billion-dollar
company I was on a podcast earlier today
guy asked me Pat what do you do if
you're 18 years only got an incredible
idea
I said stop focusing on having so many
great ideas that doesn't make any sense
stop focusing on great ideas why I don't
get what you're saying let me explain to
you why here's why say I have two people
here okay on this end I have somebody
who's got the most ridiculous idea in
the world he fits the next uber okay
it's the next Facebook it's an X
whatever you want to call it great idea
I have a guy here on this side who spent
two years mastering the skill set while
this guy just kept trying to come up
with great ideas this guy here spent two
years learning how to sell day and night
he mastered the art of selling selling
selling if I have to bet on who is more
likelihood to eventually make more money
in life I'm putting all my money on this
guy over this guy let me explain to you
why okay so I have some examples here
for you which will validate why I'm
making this point to you we have five
examples and I promise you two of them
you won't even recognize who they are
but you'll know once I make a point to
hear Mark Zuckerberg everyone knows
Facebook December 2004 they got started
by the way he'd even come out with the
idea just a Winkle Winkle boss what is
their name Winklevoss or something like
that they came up with the ideas the
Winklevoss twins came up with the idea
of Facebook but he took it you can call
it steal it whatever you want to call it
and he started coding Facebook okay we
have marks up for succor but we have
Steve Wozniak we'll learn how to create
a computer that's April for 76 we have
McDonald's brothers who started
McDonald's April 1555 we have a nick
swim swim learn by the way to even over
Nick swim barn is you know I don't even
know Nick's one - do you know where next
one - can you get some nooks one - stop
googling
it stop googling it and just stay with
the episode you don't know who mix twin
murders but you will hear in a minute do
you know who Martin Eberhard is oh my
gosh Martin Eberhard wherever you are I
hope you don't watch this episode but
there is a Martin Eberhard out then I
watch this here all of these guys were
great in ideas Zuckerberg takes the idea
from the Winklevoss brothers okay and he
starts coding with its friend Edward
they raise a $18,000 from Edward there's
so many different stories here and they
create the Facebook it was mainly for
you know Harvard your book what's called
the face book you've seen a movie before
if you haven't you should watch the
social network is in that social network
right great movie to watch and then all
of a sudden Mark Zuckerberg runs into a
sales guy named Sean Parker if you don't
know who Sean Parker is Sean Parker was
the founder of Napster this dude knows
how to sell the sales guys who sold a
vision because Mark said this could be a
million dollar business suck Parker said
no no this is a billion dollar idea he
sold the vision to everybody he came in
and sold the idea now mark is worth
fifty six billion by the way Sean Parker
the sales guy is worth 2.6 billion
you know what the Winklevoss brothers
who came up with the idea are worth two
hundred million dollars we tuned to both
of them because that's where they were
settled with they're lost 140 million
and 60 million dollars that's what they
got the idea goes now of course you're
saying Pat at least they're worth 200
million yes I would much rather be the
sales guy now let's go to the next
example stay with me here
Steve Wozniak I've been a real Steve
Wozniak many years ago if you haven't
seen it it's a fascinating interview
Wozniak found a sales guy named Steve
Jobs Steve Jobs knew how to sell Steve
Jobs had no clue what he was doing Steve
Jobs when he worked at Atari he would
ask him to do the coding phone cuz he
didn't know how to do the coding he knew
what he was doing he was the idea guy he
was a sales guy if he was alive today
his mentor will be roughly 10 billion
dollars I think Wozniak has 100 200
million dollars
nothing wrong with that still good but
the sales guy learn how to sell and I do
to the rest of the people McDonald
brothers if you haven't seen him what we
found we got to watch it
these guys knew how to start a
restaurant in San bernandino Val San
Bernardino which I've been to there was
an hour from away from where I used to
live - I just was there a couple months
ago they're doing an incredible job and
one day a guy named Ray Kroc who's a
sales guy is selling milkshake machines
one day he gets an order he's in st.
Louis in Missouri he gets an order from
McDonald brothers saying we need eight
machines he says what is this a mistake
no we need eight machines and a guy
hangs up great crimes decides to drive
to San Bernardino he goes there says oh
my gosh this is amazing this is
ridiculous this this can be something
big what if we going to scale this and
what if we do this and he starts selling
it Casey sold vision
he went to investors country clubs he
sold the vision of McDonald's Ray Kroc
you guys know Ray Kroc
I believe gave them 2.6 million dollars
to buy out the name McDonald's and then
after he bought at McDonald's guess what
they couldn't use their own name
McDonald's and Ray Kroc the sales guy
took McDonald's to where it's at right I
think there's thirty eight forty
thousand McDonald's around the world
when he died his net worth was 1.5
billion dollars his wife and him gave
the 1.5 billion dollars I believe to
some charities all of it 100% of it
that's the sales guy next next one here
Nick swim
myrn Mick swimmer you don't know what
Nick's one word is let me tell you and
mix wood burners Nick's win Laurent is
the founder of that pose
holy moly but you don't know who thinks
women is Nick's one where's the founder
of Zappos and he signs a sales guy I
guarantee you've heard of Tony Hsieh
delivering happiness Tony Hsieh comes in
ok and he says we can turn this thing
into a monstrosity and he does Tony
Hsieh goes from what he was worth to now
roughly
shy of a billion dollars he's around 850
by the way Nick was smart he kept the
shirt he's worth running a billion
dollars today now the next one Martin
Eberhard you know hallmark never heart
is by this time I think you probably
research his name to see who it is
because you're so curious and you
couldn't wait three minutes now let me
tell you who it is if you had
yet Martin Eberhard is the original
founder of Tesla
he started Tesla he started Tesla
Elon Musk is not the founder okay he is
the founder of Tesla
he started Tesla Elon Musk shows up and
he says this thing can be bigger than
any one of you guys think it is because
he sold the vision because he's a sales
guy he sold the vision to the world you
and I bought it
Tesla's now work Tesla's not worth what
it's worth and Elon Musk is worth
somewhere shout 20 billion dollars we're
gonna put his name over here okay so
what's my point here to you oh my gosh
if I get another message with another
person telling me they got a billion
dollar idea that if I team up with them
we're going to go out there and do this
and this and that all this other stuff
great I like it because I know how to
sell a vision once I buy into a product
I'm all good with this I don't have a
problem with that but I'm talking to you
I also want you to make a lot of money
focus on be kind of an incredible
salesperson focus on communication focus
on how to sell focus on looking at stuff
where you can go out and communicate it
to other people
focus on seeing the vision of something
being able to sell a product to somebody
else when I got out of military I
couldn't sell anything to anybody I can
tell anything to myself I was the worst
salesman in the world when I got out of
the military I look like a bodybuilder
because that's what I was at that time
my body was incredibly fit at that time
but I couldn't sell a membership to
anybody I worked at Bally's at Cobra
City when I worked at Bally's our covert
City it was the worst gym as from all
the ballots because it was in a basement
the place smelt it was old school was a
Nautilus gym sports connection gym but
we worked in a manager there was a guy
named Cisco who was phenomenal you know
how to sell 20 buddy
and one day I'm like I can't sell I got
to give up I can't even go out there and
do this cisco pulls me aside and says
the following thing to me substantial
before you quit the game of sale I
believe you can do good in sales but I
want you to do something I said what's
that you need to go and learn how to
sell at Fox Hills Mall Fox Hills Mall
was a mall in Culver City okay so I
should do if I can't sell memberships at
a gym with all the equipment here and
it's a 36 month contract you want me to
some memberships at a mall when no one
even sees the gym and you want me to
sign the 36 month contract with credit
cards yes okay I go to Fox Oh small I'm
standing on my boot that Fox's mother I
don't want to talk to anybody I'm
frightened of rejection I don't want to
talk to a single soul then all of a
sudden these two other guys I notice
they're around the booth I'm behind the
booth because this is my hiding spot
comfort zone so slowly I also come
around the booth and I'm still trying to
not stay as close to the boot because a
safe safe place here I saw these guys
selling a couple members I'm like wait a
minute they stole the membership at the
gym that's crazy that person signed a 36
month contract at the gym I would have
never done that then I said maybe people
will buy so then I came out I started
talking to people freely and then all of
a sudden one girl sat down first school
that bought a membership for me at the
gym $75 on $33 man I'll never forget
this I said if this girl just gave me a
credit card I can do it with everybody
then I started walking out the source
hey have you been to valid Cobra City
how come you know what a lot of
membership I remember with this why not
then all of a sudden month later became
the Rookie of the Month then I became
the rookie year then I've realized I can
sell because I believe in the product of
working out this is so easy for me then
the next thing was I like financial
services then I know I could sell it but
I didn't come out with the product of
insurance I didn't come out with the
product of annuities or stocks or bonds
or mutual funds I didn't invent those
ideas I learned how to sell then the
idea kept getting bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger by the way
I'm here to tell you the more you focus
on learning how to sell and you improve
that skill set you are always on demand
people always need you for the rest of
your career remember that people always
need a leader with sales who sees to how
they can move an army to a direction
they're always going to need someone
like that you need to focus on mastering
your skill set and stop trying to come
up with the next Apple ID or snapchat or
Facebook or any of that stuff that's
going to turn into this billion-dollar
idea I'm not telling you don't come up
with ideas but I'm going to tell you we
got a good idea here with a person that
knows how to sell very well but this is
going to sell to an investor more than a
person who's got a ridiculous idea
where's no clue how to sell no one's
going to mess them to this this one is
going to do much but
in this one all day every day twice on
Sunday so guess what my recommendation
to you is stop trying to be all these
guys that think they're going to come
out with the next idea that they're
going to be the next over of whatever or
the next Facebook or the snapchat spend
the year or to work under somebody who
knows how to sell and learn how to sell
learn how to be an incredible
communicator put yourself out in front
of people that's a little bit
comfortable uncomfortable and see what
happens to you in the world of business
because when you have to choose here you
can choose who you want to be do you
want to be McDonald's brothers do you
want to be any of these guys without
these guys none of this happens I
suggest you learn how to sell I suggest
you learn how to sell them and you
become the person that knows how to
communicate a product to somebody else
anyways you got any questions any
thoughts any other stories here that you
know about you want to share with us
that's similar to this comment on the
bottom you got any question starts also
comment on the bottom take everybody
bye-bye hey thanks for watching this
video let me make a case to you I
believe you need to subscribe to value
team and also join the notification
squad look there's two ways you can
learn about business wonder way to go to
college learn a bunch of theories by
professors what probably never run a
business before or you can watch value
taemin ran by entrepreneurs who have
built and sold businesses and you can
learn from our mistakes and what we did
right and by the way I'm willing to bet
anybody who goes and takes this boring
route verses watches I attainment I'm
putting my money this person who watches
value Tim is going to beat the person
who goes to college you don't believe me
test me on this this is why I'm so
certain you need to subscribe to value
Taemin and learn the content so you can
also be successful
[Music]